all right the edge rankings
unveiled last week by
christopher sims jalen phillips at
number one let's start with him yeah
what put him above the rest on your list
well like best pure pass rusher in the
draft and again i'm not all about like
oh sax everything like that but just
when you talk about like the most
explosive first step coming off the edge
it's jalen phillips the guy who can like
come around the edge mike and you know
you see this right those guys that can
really rush the pastor they have that
ability to like bend themselves as they
go around the corner he does all that
stuff like really naturally let alone
he's just an explosive big powerful man
like reminding me of like jpp coming out
of south florida of course the giants
picked him in the top 10 or 12 right
around there it's a lot that way mike
and doesn't mess around like you know
i'm big into like what do your bad plays
look like his bad plays are stalemates
at the line of scrimmage against tackles
but man can he get off blocks mike he
throws tight ends around he is forget
like about production because that gets
overrated with this sack stuff too much
his disruption his f the pie up ability
is real to go along with it to me clear
cut the number one edge guy in the draft
mic but he does have a little concussion
history and that'll be the question uh
as we go forward here because he went to
ucla he sat out a year of football then
came back to miami
broader observation here i think the
hardest position
to assess
heading into any draft is edge rusher
because
how do you ever properly factor in the
quality
of the left tackle or right tackle right
that the pass rusher is trying to get
around how do you factor that into your
analysis when it's possible it's just a
big slow guy yeah that that will never
make it in the nfl that this guy is
running circles around no no i i mean
that's why you try to go to games too
where you look at it and go wait this
this guy he's going against is going to
be in the nfl okay here's the clemson
game this guy's going to be in the nfl
okay hey he's still getting around the
edge you know all right that looks
pretty good and then also within that
yeah i mean it's not a perfect formula
you're right but then when you find
those guys that are like all right he's
playing a team here that doesn't have an
nfl tackle does he dominate him does he
lower to their competition
and kind of just like fall asleep at the
wheel what does he do and that's where
you know phillips to me dominates no
matter who no matter who it is and there
are enough nfl tackles you get to see
him go again so you're right it's not
it's never easy it's not and again too
you got to separate that production from
disruption and those things you know to
where too many people you know okay he's
got a teammate and and um gregory russo
right who didn't play this last year you
know the year before that had a bunch of
sacks he's a good player
but
there's a difference to me and you know
again those guys where yeah he had a
bunch of sacks but none of those sacks
were like he came off the edge and
dominated his guy mike it was like the
kind of sacks where everybody was
covered and the quarterback held it for
five seconds now he got it or somebody
else missed the sack and now the
quarterback had a move and then he got
the sack you know that's to me where you
got to separate the disruption from the
production and all of those type of
things to try to figure out the position
a little bit
the biggest challenge in that regard and
we'll pivot back to this year's class i
think back to vernon goldston
sure in 2008
right vernon goldston with jake long and
oh hey beat jake long and jake long was
the first overall pick that year gulstan
went six and he was just a disaster at
the nfl level and yeah i just think it's
so hard to project at every position it
is but i just feel like at this position
it's more difficult than others all
right take me through the rest of your
top five what what and i see vanderbilt
and vanderbilt guys aren't supposed to
make it in the nfl why do you have daiyo
odingbo at number five coming out of
vanderbilt cause he can do everything
you know first off he's like close to
280 pounds he's not necessarily like
your sac master slash edge guy that way
mike but you know a guy you could kick
inside and he could be a pain in the
butt on like third downs if he went
inside against defensive tackles but
more or not it's about you know again i
think with edge guys he could play weak
side defense and and be a handful with
athleticism and quicks to beat pass
rushers that way but also has like
strength mike to where you can make him
the strong side dn and now he's got
tight ends and a tackle in front of him
and he can be really good against double
teams or dominate those run blocking
schemes that's what that way he tore his
achilles though in january that's gonna
be a big question for him but a player
that reminded me a lot of carlos dunlap
right who just resigned back with the
seattle seahawks that's who he reminds
me of as a player coming out here mike
at number three on your list is someone
from penn state who had a grand total
of zero sacks
last year yeah how how do you look past
that when you're evaluating the film and
uh how many did you see i mean was it
just like a lot of close calls i know
that drives past rushers crazy when hey
i almost had a sack hey i almost had a
sack well yeah but all that matters is
whether you did yeah well i know but you
know and also too with college football
you got to remember it's a different
game too you got less plays every game
where a quarterback drops back right and
takes a five or a seven step drop and
they sit in the pocket and do that think
about college football it's a handoff
it's a handoff it's a quick screen oh
it's a quick screen there oh it's a fake
handoff and throw it over the middle on
an rpo i mean you could get lawrence
taylor and put nobody in front of him
and he might go through games to get get
no no sacks in college football at times
the way the game is played so yeah
there's a lot of close calls you know
there really is there is a lot of
hurries and things like that but here's
a guy too that yeah it might not be
about sex he reminds me a little bit of
a guy like leonard floyd mike that way
where you go
whoa okay wait he can get to the
quarterback but that's not like his
bread and butter but man he can shoot
gaps he can take on pulling guards and
throw them to the side and make the
tackle he gets in pass coverage and he's
as as athletic as like free safeties and
things like that so that's where his
real value as a football player is mike
it's a little bit of that leonard floyd
aldon smith back in those days stand up
on the edge i can cover or i can come
off the edge and get to the quarterback
but also be a force in the running game
uh really
shockingly good football player i wasn't
expecting to see it out of a taller
longer type of guy really physical uh
fun to watch one of the more fun watches
there was this year
what's your next category of players
that you'll be
listening oh line baby the big moo cows
there's some good ones too there is it's
it's a pretty deep class and it was not
easy but that will be coming tomorrow on
the podcast rank the top five offensive
lineman got defensive tackles coming on
later in the week all of that uh but
yeah it's it's been fun i still got you
know i got some guys to still crack
through here i'm not done i got some
work on my plate
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports